let's uh let's let's jump to this very
important story about a
harassment campaign oh no by
conservatives against a poor
a children's hospital in boston
wbur says boston children's hospital
deluged in harassment campaign
heavens
what happened
boston children's hospital become the
target of a harassment campaign based on
inaccurate information about its
transgender surgery program hospital
staff say the campaign includes
aggressive calls emails and death
threats from some providers it goes
without saying you shouldn't be sending
death threats nobody should
um however i often find that when it
comes to stories like this
concerned phone calls get called
harassment yeah that's correct so like
if you call me like i have some concerns
about what you're doing and they're like
oh i'm being harassed
quote we are deeply concerned by these
attacks on our clinicians and staff
fueled by misinformation and a lack of
understanding and respect for our
transgender community the hospital said
in a statement we are working with law
enforcement to protect our clinicians
staff patients families and the broader
boston children's community so this all
started when uh who was it was it
billboard chris
yes so chris posted a posted video from
boston children's hospital and he also
has evidence that talking about
hysterectomies well yeah
just in general he also has evidence
that they may be lying about the amount
of threats that they have because he
posted a team he posted a tweet that i
just pulled up here and it says that he
has a source within boston children's
hospital where he got all this stuff
from and he said that that most of the
people there don't even know what is
happening like he said oh that that's of
course and so like they well and and
also that there have not been ramped up
security efforts at the hospital at all
so let's
slow down we got to slow down yeah to
explain what happened so this is a video
comes up showing boston's children
hospital putting it's a promotional
video explaining hysterectomies and
bilateral uverectomy or uber they
actually had several videos up on their
site with very um
they're gone now with uh well-spoken
doctors talking about how important and
interesting these surgeries are smiling
cute music in the background
gender affirming gender affirming is
what they call it yeah lady doctors one
doctor was talking about the process of
a hysterectomy and saying that it's the
same for young adults as and for gender
affirming
treatment as it would be for anybody
else and talks about the full and
complete removal of
a woman's reproductive system no no the
bilateral overectomy is differentiated
well she talks about the whole thing
she says that
you know she says that they remove the
uterus the fallopian tubes and they
could also remove the ovaries and the
cervix
so that's that's everything that's
taking it all that's taking it all out
at once uh you have another doctor
talking about how one way that you can
tell your pre-verbal child is trans is
if they play with toys that are
stereotypically considered to be toys of
the opposite sex
how do they know that
like like
how does the child know that society has
deemed this particular
toy of a human to be a male or female
toy like a girl playing with a doll
versus a boy playing with an action
figure they're just playing with people
they're just playing with people they
also that same doctor discusses in this
very short little clip a couple of
minutes long about how if your child
doesn't want to get a haircut
maybe they are trans if your child
doesn't want to sit to pee or does want
to sit to pee then perhaps your child
your pre-verbal child is trans any mom
will tell you
i mean my son still hates getting a
haircut yeah you know he's for sure a
boy like he's you guys have all met him
like he's clearly oh yeah yeah so uh
yeah so that's insane you also have a
doctor talking about uh phalloplasties
and how a phalloplasty is done
um and that same doctor and that's one
that chris posted today that same doctor
because actually
we were all talking about this behind
the scenes and we saw them start to take
this stuff down and we were all me and
christina buttons who writes for the
post millennials we were all like record
it record it scream of course what's
happening what's happening now is you
had boston's children's hospital talking
about the gender affirming programs they
do the media comes out all of a sudden
saying it's not true they're lies you
have to be at least 18. well but they
ignore the finer details and so what
ends up happening now is you have all of
these outlets trying to claim they don't
actually provide gender affirming
surgeries interestingly there's one
particular trans person person
who quoted vice
vice ran the story saying the far
right's targeting the hospital
saying that the hospital says you have
to be at least 18. and this trans person
that's not true yes came out and said no
they it is common to give 16 year olds
gender affirming surgery and then they
mentioned that they got it and that they
need to normalize it or whatever because
that's how you get it i mean i can i can
break this down for you a little bit too
i was working on this story last week
with christina buttons who wrote it and
did an amazing deep dive into that for
post-millennial and if you look at their
documentation prior to when they changed
it on the site their forms for
how to get how to go about getting
approved for vaginoplasties
chest
reconstruction and um what's the other
one phalloplasties right they have it
all written down so they it says on
their forms uh to get a phalloplasty you
need to be between 18 and 35
to get a vaginoplasty you need to be
between and you could look at it it's in
our story we have the screenshots it's
uh
to get a vaginoplasty you need to be 17
between 17 and 30. that would be the
removal of male sexual reproductive
organs right and and the reshaping of it
into something that appears like that of
the app so a 17 year old and it is
totally sterilized yes and it also says
that 15 year olds you have to be 15 in
order to get a chest reconstruction or a
double mastectomy of healthy breasts and
what's particularly interesting
is that they change the language
afterwards the videos say exactly what
they do
they also follow
these guidelines from wpath wpap
that say uh and they say that they
follow these guidelines as do most
most gender-y clinically places they
follow these guidelines that also say
that parents if they if parents approve
these procedures they can be done at
younger ages the doctor who talks about
the phalloplasty or the vaginoplasty
says that in some cases it can be done
younger as well so yeah they're making
this up so i have here from
nih.gov
this is a report a single center case
series of gender affirming surgeries and
the evolution of specialty anesthesia
team
this is the journal of clinical medicine
mdpi
blah blah blah in there on the second
page it says
in materials and methods boston
children's hospital is a pediatric
academic hospital in the united states
providing gender affirming surgery to
patients aged 15 years to 35 years of
age
and they say including gender affirming
primary and multi-specialty care
involving inpatient and outpatient care
and they go on to mention other things a
bunch of other things but yeah uh 15
year olds right getting sex change
surgeries but they also say additionally
and on the boston children's hospital
website they have these glowing profiles
their promo profiles right of um
teens who have gone through their
program one of the teens their whole
family moved from texas in order to
access this these services and is on
puberty blockers and estrogen
and frequently has to go into the
hospital to get bone scans and things
like that because these are remarkably
dangerous drugs to take additionally
that child's parent is talking to
the hospital about how to
make sure to harvest the reproductive
material for this child who will be
fully sterilized if they go through this
procedure so that they can have like
their sperm when they are grown up they
have a that person is
13. they also have a seventh grader
who is on puberty blockers and he's
really excited about being non-binary i
want to point out here from the
conversation the tavistock clinic was
shut down in the uk after review found
that they were actually causing serious
harm to children one of the cases was a
young female who was on puberty blockers
and developed advanced osteoporosis
where her bones became extremely brittle
and were cracking
and uh that's the danger of of these of
these drugs and it's and the reason i
say that is because the nhs shut down
the program now we can look at these
other european countries that are held
up as like the pinnacle of health care
by the left they talk about their
scandinavia they're ending it all
they're saying it's bad it's hurting
kids now the uk is saying yeah we can't
do this well about time the united
states starts paying attention where
these other countries are talking right
but we have people who are making far
too much money off of this if you look
at some of the reporting that jennifer
billick did has done right she's done
these deep dives into capitalism she's
done these deep dives into the
pharmaceutical industry and found that
the amount of money being generated from
giving these off-label drugs to kids
performing these surgeries it's huge and
now you have the bud administration
pressing for insurance companies to
cover this or else those insurance
companies are considered discriminatory
however why is it that
it is discriminatory for insurance
companies to not cover breast
augmentation for men
but it's not discriminatory for
insurance companies to not cover breast
augmentation for women in fact if you
look at the supreme court ruling on
bostock which said that what's her name
uh amy schneider the man who was trans
and was going to the funeral home
dressed um in women's clothing right so
the supreme court said you can't fire
amy because amy uh if you fire amy for
wearing women's clothing you are
discriminating against amy on the basis
that amy is a man because a woman would
not be fired for wearing women's clothes
this was a supreme court right this was
the supreme court what basically this
that basically uh uh codified gender
identity as protected under right to
divorce civil rights exactly so that's
what bostock did now if you are saying
if you are requiring insurance companies
to give boob jobs to men on the basis
that it's discriminate discriminatory
against their gender identity to not
fund it that's what they're doing this
is what the bi-administration has
instructed medicaid to do under hhs
huh yes
i wrote about this for human events yeah
so
what's interesting is
is it not discriminatory
to tell a woman that she cannot affirm
her female gender identity free boob
jobs free boob jobs for men though not
for women not for women i think that's
discriminatory because you're only
you're discriminating against a woman's
gender identity by not letting her get
boob jobs first you can put it simply
you can't provide to one sex
so i think medicaid really needs to step
it up and start providing plastics boob
jobs for women for free additionally
most guys in this country no way yeah
sex work is work y'all right so don't
you think that underprivileged women
should have the opportunity to further
their careers in sex work
by getting free boob jobs yeah your
medications need boobs to be good at sex
let's just get that on the table i'm i'm
just in awe of the fact that i'm just
saying
i mean all of the fact that we're even
like having this conversation like what
the hell
the hell are we doing this conversation
literally
ever since the large hadron collider
fired up in 2016 this is the our
universe has been we're imploding
because they don't want to be men
and they they just they maybe they just
want to stay home and play with them
you're speaking my mind greg like i'm
like why is a hard one to go like but i
think people need to hear it they need
to look
look look
we'll we'll keep it to the basics of the
law and i think the challenge with the
law is you can't have moral logic
in the law otherwise you will get things
you don't want so
i mentioned this a couple times but i'll
break it down this way
the left says
we want gender identity to be protected
the law then says okay that has to be
defined in such a way that anyone can
understand it so in new york they say
gender identity is self-expression but
self-expression is so broad it now
starts to encompass literally anything
and now they actually say that any
gender that you come up with or clothes
you wear
so the the
what ends up happening is
when you say
we shouldn't allow the government to you
know pay for plastic surgery or whatever
you get the question of well what about
this person needs gender affirming care
to save their life okay we'll allow that
okay well but what about a woman who
also has depressive is depressed for
having small breasts she needs it for
the exact same reason she's depressed
she's having suicidal ideation and
believes talked to her therapist that
breast implants would uh alleviate the
depression body dysmorphia
then you based on the the moral logic or
the it's we have to provide it to
everybody right well now i don't think
well actually i should say i think the
left probably would be on board with
that but this is this is where it gets
difficult for you know where we are
if you would argue that in florida
parents have the final say in what
medical treatments their kids get and
what their kids learn that includes a
parent choosing to give their kid a sex
change operation
so if you if you don't want the
government mandating vaccines
then then i think it's just you to come
out and say it's not about moral logic
and consensus consistency in the law
it's about upholding your values and
your values will say the government
should stop one thing but should not
stop the other based on your personal
beliefs so do you think parents should
be allowed to
amputate their children's legs
well i'm not saying one way or the other
what i'm saying like should that be
legal but this is my point right hell
you think unless there's a threat to the
kid's life so why should they be allowed
to amputate their i think the answer is
clearly yes dicks like don't you think
it's
should a parent be allowed to bring
their kid to the doctor get their legs
amputated yes absolutely healthy legs
would you say healthy i'm staying
healthy that's the caveat right so
here's the issue if a kid has got a mrsa
or gangrene or something or a serious
catastrophic injury and the doctor says
i believe the leg should be amputated
how does the government if they're
seeking to intervene to prevent healthy
amputations determine fast enough in
this circumstance this is the challenge
of hard moral logic in the law we have
to recognize it's about values and not
about saying government should or
shouldn't so if a parent goes to the
doctor the doctor says if we don't cut
this leg off the kid's gonna get a blood
infection and die and then the
government goes that leg looks fine to
me you're amputating your kid's healthy
leg well now we go back to the christian
scientists remember who refused medical
treatment across the board and i think
ended up getting sued for that right
what didn't the supreme court make a
decision on christian scientists who
don't want to bring
medical treatment for their kids well
it's it's a big it's a big challenge
this was a lot this was like when i was
a kid they were talking about this but i
think there's like a distinction to be
made about you know if you're losing the
like example of a parent saying that
they just want to amputate their their
kid's leg for shits and gigs but no one
is saying that when it comes to when it
comes to gender affirmation the parents
are saying i'm concerned my kid will
kill themselves because they've become
depressed and they're having suicidal
ideation okay but now a lot of these
institutions are just speeding these
kids through as we learn from helena
kirchner and many other de-transitioners
they walk in and there's like an hour
consultation before they're given
powerful drugs so the issue is when it
comes to should parents should parents
have final say you run into a challenge
of saying i strict i stick to the strict
uh reality of law no you don't you would
say no you can't amputate the genitals
of this child that's wrong government
should stop you however in other
circumstances you want the parents to
have total discretion
see my view is parents can have
discretion but i would like to ban them
from surgically mutilating the bodies of
their children i don't think i can be a
hypocrite for saying that i want
government to come in and say you are
not allowed to do this this is evil this
is hurting children you're also not
allowed to beat your children yeah like
this is my fault
like there have been no long-term
studies about what the effects of these
drugs do to kids over time like there
have been no long-term studies this is
the point i'm making you cannot make the
argument that parents should have final
say if you believe there are
circumstances where they should not
it says so so we went through this with
the parental rights and education bill
where everyone said parents have a right
to determine what their kids are
learning and i say i agree with that and
there are there are circumstances we had
someone on recently
we were talking about uh if parents
don't want to give their kid you know
cancer treatment should the government
intervene take their kids away and they
said yes the government absolutely
should and i'm like no way i completely
opposed bethany mandela
that's christian that's the i watched
that episode that's the uh i don't think
that's christian scientist knows
everything and i think there's there's
very difficult questions in what's right
for your children and the last thing i
want is for the government to come in
and say we're injecting your child
against your will with something you
know
not every parent is a doctor not every
you know most parents are not doctors
considering and so there's a real
challenge of when you let the government
come in and decide what medical
treatments you have to get yeah there
isn't they already
surgery but they already do that like
they do that with like there are
vaccines that you have to get in order
to send a child to public school like
they're doing that but there are
exemptions to those i'm pretty sure and
i still i i
you know there there are tough questions
about
the government coming and saying because
you did not do this we're taking your
children away and well you don't have to
do it but you can't come to our place if
you didn't right
there's a polio outbreak in new york
right now because people didn't get
their kids vaccinated is that why though
yes i mean this is new york
new york new york is full of is full of
anti-vaxxers well no it's happening
mostly i think isn't it
isn't it happening mostly in the
orthodox jews yeah it's happening mostly
in rockland county in the um because
because orthodox jews don't don't
believe in any of that well because i
called my kid's doctor i was like so
polio what's the deal what are we doing
now and he was like uh it's unvaccinated
is what it is and i was like oh that's
still i'm gonna with a grain of salt i
don't know i don't know why people are
getting polio sometimes diseases come
out they tell you it's for one reason
turns out it's for another reason
oh interesting yeah but i just think
like just when it comes to you know
mutilation of a healthy child's bodies
who have gender dysphoria and need help
that doesn't involve going through a sex
change operation when you're 13 or 14
years old i don't see why i i don't see
why you can take the position of parents
rights while also saying this should be
illegal because this is wrong and it's
hurting people and it's causing
irreversible damage to children every
day i think if if you do that to your
children you are abusing your children
and child abuse is what we consider to
be legal or illegal i've got uh i went
to antique store and they had 340 life
magazines from like 1940 to 1970.
amazing i bought them all and we're
going to put together like a reading
area so we can basically what i want to
do is i want to
like
sort them that's the word sort them all
by date
and then do a kind of like breakdown of
stories at the time how they were
reported versus what we know now because
we have like vietnam stuff but i bring
this up because thalidomide yeah i was
just gonna is one of the magazines that
i have oh when it was great thalidomide
great mother's anti-nausea medicine
you're pregnant take this and then the
kids had no arms right you're like they
were all weird yeah they're like their
arms yeah they had just like hands on
their shoulders yeah and it was like was
it for morning sickness or whatever it
was for morning sickness yeah now what i
don't want
here's here's the challenge when when a
new treatment comes out there's a per
there's a person have a right to try it
does it like if a drug comes out and
says this will treat your morning
sickness whenever right to take it well
yeah trump trump signed right to try
into law no no but that's that's when
you're dying i'm talking about an
anti-nausea medicine comes out women
will take it and then all of a sudden a
few years later we're like whoopsie why
don't you think that there should be a
controls process but but there is
remember remember that was that birth
control that got recalled i don't know
the name but whatever the worth of
tricyclin they all get recalled at some
point there was some commercial that was
really popular and like a year later
they were like gardasil i don't know i
don't know gardasil is the hpv vaccine
yeah they they they recalled it or
whatever the the issue is
if there's something being sold and
there's some treatment right so like um
you know joe rogan talks about nad and
stuff
and uh luke was on the show talking
about stem cell therapy where they give
you an iv and flood your body with stem
cells to repair damage and it's like
what's the long-term effects of that
because we've not been doing that for a
long time should people have a right to
try that if they want there's
they say it's safe they say it can be
used to treat cancer my point is you
could get a treatment and then it turns
out it's really really bad you know like
thalidomide these women were like hey
this medicine's gonna make me not feel
sick and then their kids had no arms
like totally crazy stuff and then once
they found out they're like we gotta
stop doing that
so you know ultimately what it comes
down to is
i don't think the government should
mandate and then there are questions
about what the limits we set are when
the government can mandate it's not as
simple as to say
the government can or can't it's a
simple to say we have values and we've
determined in some areas we won't allow
it in some areas we will
i'm i mean yeah like i just take the
position that child abuse is illegal
like i consider this child abuse if you
are doing this to your kid who has
gender dysphoria because like why do a
lot of parents like tran put their
child's their children through this is
because they really care about them or
are they just like really woke and want
to be cool in front of their friends i
think it varies i think i think it
varies a lot too but like it is still
child abuse to do this and child abuse
is illegal like we don't allow parents
to abuse their children because because
that's parents rights like that would be
illegal they would be arrested for that
of my a good friend of mine her daughter
is going through this now
and she was convinced to
push her daughter into this direction
because
the psychologist said that her daughter
was going to kill herself okay but like
we're seeing like that that suicide
rates are up a lot with people who go
through this as well this was about six
years ago so
that's where they are they're dealing
with this now thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there